aujourd'hui c'est un truc important ça a
toujours été un moment que j'aime bien
petit je choisis si le mr avait là sinon
ce n'est pas quand on est six comme
annie guerrier je suis content et je
t'attends plasticienne c'est quand on
est beaucoup
il ya beaucoup des géniaux que je ne
connais pas qui mais aussi choisir le
bon matériel bon c'est sûr j'ai changé
le bon bout la bonne coup j'ai mis
beaucoup
elle croise l'école maintenant de faire
les élèves et l'école roche avec
d'autres de se mettre et les pouvoirs
j'ai peur un peu de me perdre
même si la lettre h hélas si compliqué
tout c'est plus un argument peut piquer
pour l'heure à cause de mon handicap que
je grandis pas comme les autres la
menthe et aussi que limite c'est pour
être comme les autres les braqueurs
n'ont pas trait à cet exercice soit
élevé en fût il paraît qu'il ya beaucoup
de devoirs roulement femmes
[Musique]
ce serait bien de vous détendre un peu
gêné coûtant 20 santé dans le sens et
votre tension matière
votre visite récente de mettre au sport
à la marche ou à la méditation
ils sont consignées comme ça ont
souhaité vous rencontrer ce matin jour
de la rentrée scolaire le collège
qu'elle influe reavie un renouveau
depuis un an il est le fruit d'un
travail collaboratif au sein du collège
est d'autant plus cette année avec
l'ouverture du dispositif ulis et nous
mettrons tout en oeuvre pour contribuer
à leur rythme et leur épanouissement
donner le meilleur donner le meilleur de
soi même
je sais faire preuve d'humilité en
raison tout en étant fiers de ce que
vous êtes
ça lui est offerte à tous
l'équipe adam elle vit aujourd'hui à
rien n'obligeait pas ils mangèrent dans
mon vient de sortir des nouvelles
oui je mais je pense pas que je vais
réussir mais je pense que monsieur
payette à 12 à condition de concerne moi
si je suis pris au jeu de g enfin je dis
ce que je pensais de sa mixture wiley
sur l'égalité le respect des différences
et du handicap il faut bien respecter et
les aider parce que ce n'est pas leur
faute ils n'ont pas choisi ce handicap
est là bas tu vois le genre ouais ah oui
le collège accueille son guide de
famille ah oui je suis au courant
beaucoup disent que la nature des fonds
dont je fus m'attire al dans la lande a
senti je suis tombé 1 / il est resté
quelques jours tu m'as benson la
différence en irak ont fusé mentir je
sais pas si le dispositif est liste il
ya mille raisons d'aimer handicapés et
respecté on peut être par exemple des
marrons des beaux gosses des sacré
cuisinier et grands des gens sympas on
peut aussi être des vrais cons des vrais
cons comme tout le monde
pas plus pas moins alors respectez nous
pour la boîte maison de monsieur le
principal voilà ce que je dis à
paillettes encore au mieux je balance
tout en pleine face à payet bayer des
monts sutton mais bien un peu trop mais
c'est bien cette fois qu'un poids qu'on
a envoyés dans son bureau la vie l'année
prochaine celle de solutions comme
toujours
ça n'a pas marché
enfin pas pour toi que je t'aime je te
fais oublier c'est pas compliqué ici
réfléchissent avec 2 un an à se battre
ou un an tranquille sur le moment où ton
message in a comme s'il avait gagné un
triste d'équidés lendemain
[Applaudissements]